Voiceover: What I want to do in this video
is think about the
different ways to make five.
What do I mean about that?
Right over here we have
three plus something,
so there's some unknown
number right over here.
Three plus something is
going to be equal to five.
In this diagram we have three circles here
that represents the three
and then we have five boxes.
One, two, three, four, five.
How many more circles do
we need in order to fill up
all the five boxes?
We've clearly already filled three.
Well, let's think about it.
We just have to add one and two circles.
Now we have a total of five.
Three blue ones and two
of this purple color
or I guess this pink color.
We see that three plus
two is equal to five.
That mystery number
here, that blank is two.
Three plus two is equal to five.
Now over here we have two
plus a mystery number
is equal to five again.
Once again, we have five spaces
and two of them are filled in with this
kind of purple, pink stars.
How many more do we have to fill in
in order to fill in all five boxes,
two plus what is equal to five.
I encourage you to pause the video
and think about it.
I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
Let's think about how
many more of this boxes
we need to fill in, in order
to fill in all five of them.
We need to fill in one,
two, and three of the boxes
in order to fill out all five.
Now we have five stars.
We have two of the pink ones
and we have three of the blue ones.
We can say that two plus three,
the mystery number here is three.
Two plus three is equal to five.
Let's do a few more of this.
Here I have four plus some mystery number
is equal to five.
I filled out four of the five boxes,
how many more do I need to fill in
in order to have five things,
in order to have all
five boxes filled out.
Well we see very clearly here
that there is exactly one box
that we need to fill in
or one box that we need
to add to the other four.
We see that four plus
one is equal to five.
Now let's go the other way.
We have the five boxes, only
one of them is filled in.
How many more of these smiley faces
do we need to add, in order
to fill in all the boxes?
Or another way of thinking about it,
we have one,
how many more do we need to add to one
to get to five?
Like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and think about it on your own.
Well, let's see, we can add one,
we can add two, we can add three,
and four yellow smiley faces.
We could say one, one we
have one white smiley face
plus one, two, three,
four yellow smiley faces
is equal to five.
You see a pattern here.
Let's start at the beginning.
Three plus two is equal to five,
and two plus three is equal to five.
When you had three filled in,
you needed two more to get to five.
When you had two filled in,
you needed three more to get to five.
Notice three plus two, two plus three.
Same thing over here,
four plus one is equal to five,
one plus four is equal to five.